many are calling Armas current track the
worst case scenario for South Florida
now this is a look at the category 4
hurricane from the international space
station chief weather caster Lonnie
Quinn of our New York station WCBS is
here to explain why Irma's impact will
be felt far from the center of the storm
Lonnie good morning well good morning
everybody look let's be real every inch
of a hurricane is dangerous and every
hurricane is different so let's take a
moment and break down the anatomy of
airmen because with ARMA we have really
got to focus on the winds and the storm
surge now that hole that you see in the
very middle of the hurricane that's the
eye that's where you're gonna find very
peaceful air but just outside the eye is
the eye wall and this is where you find
these strongest winds
Irma's 155 mile-per-hour winds are
confined to a band that is just 35 miles
from the eye so wherever that eye is
making landfall that is where you get
the most devastating damage and just
outside of this there's another band of
hurricane-force winds not quite as
strong they extend an additional 35
miles and here's where you find winds
that are sustained at about 75 74 miles
per hour or stronger but not as strong
as that Iowa and the rest of this huge
storm is primarily tropical storm force
winds and those are winds that are 39
miles per hour or stronger they go out
another 140 miles this thing is enormous
but keep in mind you can always get some
stronger wind gusts and it sort of
anywhere in the hurricane but it also
matters what side of the storm that
you're on the worst part of storm is the
front right quadrant that's because
you're getting all the peak winds but
now it's combined with the forward
progress of the storm this is also the
part of the storm that's gonna pop and
spawn a lot of tornadoes now on the left
side it's still dangerous don't get me
wrong but the winds are gonna be a
little bit a little bit less because you
now have to subtract the forward motion
so look I'll tell you it's a beast no
matter how you look at it and either
it's the top of the storm or the bottom
of the storm pushing water onshore for
the East Coast pushing water onshore for
the west coast storm surge is a huge
problem Charlie thank you lion it's
interesting to me in terms of how much
you warn people there's still people
that feel like they would want to stay
they want to stay and even though we
know that the winds are going to be so
bad the storm surge is going to
so bad we're hearing lots of anecdotal
reporting but people are staying in
Miami I know people in the Naples area
to her this morning are saying now I'm
really scared
I've just got about 24 hours to make a
decision about what to do especially
even when you hear that this is expected
to be greater than Hurricane Andrew we
remember the impact it had on the state
and yet some people are saying in each
moment you delayed the decision
party party exactly right mm-hmm